bonsoir à vous messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france 3e
samedis consécutifs de mobilisation
contre l'opa sanitaires et toujours plus
de manifestants en plus de 200000
aujourd'hui contre 160 et 150000 ces
deux dernières semaines alors le mois
d'août est ce qu'il promet d'être
compliqué pour le gouvernement vous
croyez stéphane rozès on voit une
augmentation des manifestement par tiers
par semaine
la mobilisation va sans doute se
maintenir dans le camion s'est plutôt
stable 35% des français soutiennent les
manifestants donc et deux tiers ne les
soutient pas mais le vrai rendez vous
sera la rentrée
pourquoi parce que pour l'heure le
mouvement est assez divers en a entendu
dans vos reportages il ya les anti
système
dans la continuité des gilets jaunes
il ya les anti vaccins ou un principe de
précaution
et il ya les anti-pacs center pour un
principe de liberté
alors pourquoi je parle de la rentrée
c'était la dernière intervenante c'est
que on ya une inconnue qui est ce qui va
se passer dans les entrepôts line et
comment risque des prix par beaucoup de
salariés au fond la menace qui pourrait
y avoir justement des menaces contre les
salariés n'aient n'étaient pas vaccinés
et donc ça c'est une hypothèque qui fait
le vrai rendez vous sera à mon avis
septembre
renater vous êtes d'accord pour vous
parce que c'est en début ou alors faut
s'attendre aussi un essoufflement il ne
peut être une reprise à la rentrée comme
l'indiquent stéphane rozès
c'était un très beau succès aujourd'hui
à vis des rassemblements dans des
centaines de villes de france dont
certains très gros rassemblements on a
manifesté avec peut plus vivre aux côtés
des patriotes à montparnasse et on
revendique 100 mille manifestants les
images circulant sur internet chacun
chacun en jugera
il est évident que l'été ne facilite pas
les mobilisations et je partage aussi ce
que ce qu'a dit monsieur rozès je pense
en plus que le passé ni terre n'est pas
encore entré dans la vie concrète des
français jusqu'aujourd'hui
chacun peut encore accéder au bar ou au
restaurant que les salariés ne sont pas
encore tenu de présenter un bassin
sanitaire valide et donc je pense
effectivement que la rentrée sera une
nouvelle étape dans la mobilisation avec
une prise de conscience j'espère encore
plus large des dangers pour notre
démocratie pour nos principes d'égalité
de liberté de fraternité que représente
7 e ce dispositif
stéphane rozès il ya des gilets jaunes
qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui c'était le
cas les semaines passent et comment vous
percevez vous leur présence dans au sein
des cortèges
je pense que la fin du mouvement des
filets jaunes a été un moment de
radicalisation politique de nature un
peu différente
la différence entre mouvements des
gilets jaunes --mouvement actuelle c'est
que les deux tiers des français
soutenaient ou début mai me lécher john
d'un obstant les violences le soutien à
le garder chez les jaunes a baissé et
les mobilisations dans la rue ont
également baissé quantitativement quand
le président mac ont entamé le grand
dialogue
alors il ya des chez les jaunes quelques
leaders des gilets jaunes qu'ils sont là
il s'agit d'un mouvement le mouvement
actuel du nature tout à fait différente
selon moi j'avais créé des choses
là-dessus léger les journées des
michettes c'est à dire comme sous
l'ancien régime
appellation du souverain par câble aux
questions fiscales et sociales mais pour
terreau souverain racault subrin ses
devoirs notamment bien dessous panique
pour moi le mouvement actuel est de
nature différente mais les questions de
senneterre et dans des questions trans
idéologique transpartisane il n'est pas
au fond incroyable que si elle dresse
également le reliquat du groupe qui sont
devenus de militants qui sont venus
antisystème à l'airé nitel tout à
l'heure stéphane rozès parler des
antilles système des antilles passe des
anti vaccins qui se mobilisent avec des
gilets jaunes aussi contre justement
l'extension du passé ni terre depuis
trois semaines maintenant vous êtes vous
étiez du côté de montparnasse avec
florian philippot qui avait rappelé
comme la semaine dernière à à se
mobiliser
c est ce que vous vous est ce que la
classe politique finalement notamment
fait rempli de filippo se retrouvent
pour surfer sur cette convergence en vue
éventuellement des échéances à venir
notamment la présidentielle il ya là de
l'opportunisme politique ou si non je
crois pas du tout les patriotes c'est
notre cas aussi c'était leur trente
septième semaine de mobilisation dans la
rue et on a vécu dès samedi où on était
quelques uns sous la grêle bien seul et
donc on avait tout à perdre ou réalité à
s'engager chacun d'entre nous que ce
soit à titre politique à titre
professionnel donc il ya une vraie
démarche de sincérité d'ailleurs que
florian philippot avait souhaité ouvrir
à tout le monde où nous accueillir
vraiment dès le début son se demander ce
qu'on pensait ou de quels horizons
politiques
nous venions et je sens effectivement un
discours naître autour de 1 du corps un
peu de division et moi j'appelle tous
ceux qui s'opposent aujourd'hui à se
passe pour dire ce qu'on essaye de
préserver ce sont les conditions aussi
du débat démocratique vous avez ce point
très inquiétant je trouve
le projet de loi le gouvernement a
refusé un amendement
et puis tes jetons sont forgés qui
visait à exclure les bureaux de vote du
passé de terre il ya des vrais sujets
démocratiques et l'enjeu c'est de
préserver les conditions du débat pas
d'être d'accord sur tout donc oui il ya
des gens qui viennent de plusieurs
horizons politiques il faut s'en
féliciter il faut essayer de rester une
dans ce combat commun parce que l'enjeu
est double mérite véritablement on va
regarder les réactions politiques
notamment les tweets de marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon
le gouvernement doit entendre la
légitime inquiétude exprimée temps sur
l'efficacité que sur les atteintes à la
liberté et à l'égalité que suscite le
pass annie terre il est encore temps de
faire marche arrière
les marges de ce samedi doivent être
comprise et respectée
le pass sanitaire est une fausse bonne
idée un contrôle généralisé absurde
incohérent et dangereux par à l'illusion
de protection qu'il répand alors est-ce
qu'il est encore temps de faire marche
arrière à ce qu'une évolution du pass
sanitaire est encore envisageable avant
le 9 août stéphane rozès ya différentes
dimensions ya évidemment la première
unis pensent tous
la dimension politique
est ce l'un exécutive peu après s'être
engagé tellement avons reculé
cela me semble difficile parce que il
n'ya pas seulement la question de sauver
la face et a le sentiment qu'il peut
avoir
qui est double le premier dont on a un
passé que réellement l'exécutif comme
beaucoup de gouvernements craignent la
nouvelle vague du variant il le cren
réellement parce que pour eux il exclut
de revenir vers leur confinement
la seconde c'est qu'ils pensent à tort
ou à raison aux risques de divisions que
la montée des hospitalisations
le fait que le fait d'être
ni réserve quand même beaucoup plus de
pétrole qu'il disait le fait d'être
vaccinées ne fait part que ne sera
jamais hospitalisé mais je crois que les
chiffres disent que n'a peu près ma fois
moins de chances d'être hospitalisée si
on est vacciné donc en un mot là la
tension entre un gouvernement qui craint
comme tous les gouvernements l'arrivée
de la nouvelle vague et l'île des
coffrets y aura une pression telle que
même les opposants rhétorique ou les
opposants manifestent un devin
citoyennes seront obligés d'en passer
par là
au risque que ce phénomène de masse ne
suscite la mécanisation d'une forte
minorité du pays et qu'au fond l'opinion
même si elle n'est pas anti vaccins ou
anti pas se disent que quand même
l'exécutif a divisé le pays sur cette
question parce que ce débat traverse non
seulement les familles petit mais même
les familles elles mêmes assez frappant
de voir comme au sein même famille d'une
même famille harrach où paris des amis
les gens peuvent se déchirer
donc voilà une situation très délicate
pour le politique qu'il fait que les
cinq bien dans les réactions même le pen
et jean luc mélenchon au fond aucun
leader politique n'a une vision d'une
grande netteté dans les tensions entre
le cndd et le politique sont forts
rémi tales alors comment sortir de cet
hymne au vélo que vient de décrire
stéphane rozès très justement revenons
je le crois vraiment qu'il ya une crise
sanitaire fnca doit être traitée on n'a
pas donné les moyens l'hôpital de le
faire vous avez 1800 ligue qui ont été
supprimés depuis le début du mois de
janvier
quels sont les traitements est
complètement inculte et alors
aujourd'hui on a des études sérieuses
qui montre qu'il ya des traitements qui
permet d'éviter les formes graves du
code gide et puis bien sûr la
vaccination pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables encore ces personnes
puissent bien sûr il y avoir accès
aujourd'hui juste dire que les principes
en démocratie ne sont pas inventés pour
le temps calme bien au contraire
d'ailleurs les principes ils sont aussi
créés pour tenir servir de boussole dans
les moments de crise et on ne peut pas
remettre en cause
2500 ans d'éthique médicale des siècles
de réflexion politique sur la façon dont
une société peut vivre démocratiquement
et en respectant chacun à l'occasion de
cette crise sanitaire qui est bien
réelle mais qu'il faut traiter comme
telle qui ne veut pas servir de prétexte
un changement de régime et c'est
malheureusement ce qui est en train de
se passer aujourd'hui
merci à vous rémi tales je rappelle que
vous êtes co fondateur du collectif peu
plus libre et merci à vous également
stéphane rozès politologue président de
cap
enseignant à hec et sciences-po